foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by Jade warshaw and we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ben is kicking us off in Idaho Falls Ben
welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks thanks for taking my call what's
going on
hey so just a quick question I wanted to
get an opinion on
um
my wife and I are looking at vehicles
and
just wondering
uh for a second opinion on how much to
responsibly spend
um was also trying to get something
reliable that's going to last a long
time
cool uh do you guys have any debt
well you do not awesome and uh what's
your income looking like
um about 60 60k and you said this would
be your second vehicle right
correct okay how much how much is the
first vehicle that you have what's it
worth
probably about 3 500. oh okay so you
guys are frugal frugal have you been
saving already
we have but not specifically for this I
just need a vehicle for my job
specifically a truck
um
and just kind of wondering how much I
can
you know plan on spending responsibly
well do you have do you have any you
don't have any savings saved up three to
six months or anything like that
we we do so we actually have
about 50 000. oh okay and that was
originally just toward that was actually
just towards the house and
and just savings okay so you've got your
three to six months bundled up with just
kind of General miscellaneous savings so
what I would do is I would separate the
six month Mark like I would separate out
what you need for three to six months of
expenses in your case let's go for six
months and then what would you have what
is the extra on top
um out of that 50k that you could
potentially spend on a vehicle
foreign
probably
10 to 20 it's depending on how much we
wanted to continue to put into our Roth
IRA okay judging by the sound of your
voice it doesn't sound like you want to
spend a whole lot it sounds like you're
kind of a Frugal guy and you're just
trying to get something to get by am I
reading that correctly
yeah I have a hard time justifying
spending a lot on stuff like that that
goes down in value yeah that's cool oh
my kind of guy nothing wrong with that
at all so the question becomes what kind
of truck could Ben get with twenty
thousand dollars cash something great
and there begins your research
yes let's start researching look and
look and see what you find maybe kind of
have a round number in your head already
maybe you've thought oh no 8 000 is fine
10 000 is fine start looking in that
range and if you like what you see then
go for it but if you're feeling like you
know this is really not getting me where
I want to be you know up at a couple of
thousand and start looking in that range
but you're really just you know process
of elimination here start set a low bar
and then just go from there and see if
you find anything uh that fits because
truth be told and I'm just giving you
permission to spend here you could spend
you know if you said you have twenty
thousand dollars Beyond
um that six month point of savings you
could spend it there's nothing saying
that you can't spend that money
um on a vehicle so there's your
permission to spend but if you don't
want to you don't have to you get to
choose here and that's the beauty of the
baby steps when you walk them through
and you do it the right way as you have
then you have the freedom of choice
which is great there's no problem in my
I don't see any problems here this is
this is all freedom of choice so this is
a good thing and the only parameter I
would say that we recommend is to not
have everything that has a motor and add
it all up make sure that's not more than
half of your annual income and so for
you guys that would be 30k so your car
is worth let's call it 4K well you got
some wiggle room there yeah so we could
spend you know roughly 26 000 on this
car and it wouldn't be a large part of
our world we can part with that money
without it affecting our financial
future and so think about it that way
and so maybe your upper limit is 25 and
that might mean you get the 2015 instead
of the 2018 and so there's going to be
some compromises especially because
trucks are just so freaking expensive
have you looked into the truck that you
actually would want
uh just different models that I think
would be reliable yes okay
and that's another thing you can search
is the reliability of the year you're
looking at with that engine and you can
see all the recalls and all the issues
it's had and whatever you decide to go
with always get a pre-purchase
inspection from the mechanic of your
choice
another thing you might want to consider
here I don't know what shape the other
vehicle you have the one that's you know
3500 but that might be something to
consider if that one's kind of on the
fritz or if you think that the time is
coming to replace that one soon or
upgrade that one soon you might also
want to continue uh to to factor that
into your choice as well
right yeah that makes sense so hopefully
that helps you out Ben yeah way to go I
mean this is a good problem to have it's
usually people calling in that are broke
who are like well I'm gonna go spend 60
Grand on a car on a truck with a little
payments on it yeah I know this guy's
smart Ben is smarter than that I I like
that he doesn't mentality part with that
hard earned money we love to see it all
right let's go to zahava in Brooklyn New
York oh I like that welcome to the show
hi Hi how are you good let's get
straight to the question we're up
against the clock today
okay so I've only been listening to you
for a couple of weeks my husband and I
decided we're going to look into our
budget see how we're doing we are not in
debt things come full circle but it
seems like our expenses are kind of
everywhere some things come out of the
bank account like the mortgage some
things come off the credit card some
things we end up paying tuition you know
the cleaning lady gets cash and yeah
lady gets a check and we put gift cards
for the you know day camp and how do we
consolidate to really see how much we're
making where every dollar is going also
in terms of what we're making sometimes
I'm on a W-2 sometimes I'm on a 1099 and
my husband works in Jersey but was in
New York how do we get everything
together yeah you know I would suggest
getting on everydollar.com it's the
budgeting software that we created here
at Ramsey Solutions and it's amazing
I've been using it since 2017 and in
there not only can you track all of your
expenses
um pretty not in real time but pretty
close to real time what it does is it
automatically uh connects to your bank
and so all the transactions that you
make with every dollar premium will go
directly into your every dollar budget
and you can literally track them so
anytime you go to Publix or the grocery
store track it under your grocery budget
anytime you pay for daycare or whatever
you track it under the daycare and you
can really start to see how you're
spending and it's great because it'll
break out those expenditures into
percentages so you can see man I'm
putting 15 of my income towards XYZ or
I'm putting you can really see how
you're spending and for you since you
sometimes have the irregular income they
have a really great feature on there
that's called paycheck planning and so
it literally allows you to bring
balances over from the previous month so
if if you and your husband did really
well that month and you didn't spend all
the money you can bring that balance
over and then if you have them coming up
month you can see how that's going to
track with you so you can plan when
you're going to spend your money what
date you're going to spend it on and it
will tell you hey you're close to going
in the red or you know you're you're
spending looks good it'll tell you green
or red so every dollar budget that's
what you need to get onto zahaba and
that's part of our every dollar premium
so we're going to gift that to you
zahava for one year and start tracking
it may take a few months to dial all the
expenses in for those checks they're
coming out of your bank and so
everything at some point has to come out
of your bank and that will help you gain
control of this we're rooting for you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined by Jade warshaw this hour the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
Tanisha joins us up next in Washington
D.C Tanisha welcome to the show
hi thank you how are you we're doing
great how can we help
um I would call
about whether I should change jobs or
not
or not what's making you think that you
maybe should change
well I've been doing uh Ramsay ish for
about a year and a half and um I've had
about almost 20 000 and like credit card
debts okay and now I want to tackle my
um my student loans so I have two jobs
okay but I don't it's not sustainable so
I'm like but I mean but I was able to
pay the debt off so I'm like should I
push jobs should I keep it what are you
earning between the two jobs and how
does it break down
so with one job I'm making a little
under 49 and the other job I make about
like 17
uh like 17 a little over 17.50 an hour
so I don't know how much it is usually I
don't remember so the first one is 49
000 a year is that what you were saying
yeah okay and then the other one is
17.50 an hour how many hours a week are
you working it
comes my main job
uh the one where I make 49 to 40 hours
but the other one is varies between
20 to 40 hours every two weeks
20 to 40 every two weeks and are you in
control of the 20 to 40 or is that like
hey we're just giving you what we have
do you have the ability to oh okay I'm
in control of it okay do you like both
job jobs
um I don't like my main job I like the
flexibility of it
what are you doing for work for your
main job what kind of work is it I'm a
research assistant in cardiology and I
don't do face patient facing I'm just
like I'm at home four days a week and I
go in one day a week and it's just uh
it's a recent Imaging research what do
you want to be doing in an Ideal World
regard let's say you could make as much
as you're making or more is there
something where you're like man I really
wanna I wanna be working with people
instead of behind the scenes I want to
be doing this over here
I want to be working with people but I
don't know how like I really don't know
I mean you seem like a people person are
you not I am a people person yes so
don't tell me you don't know how you're
good with people you don't know what the
next step is to take to jump into that
career and we can help with that part
and our friend Ken Coleman has some
great resources that will hook you up
with today one is the get clear career
assessment
and this will take you about 20 minutes
you'll fill this out it'll give you a
report that will not only give you some
career options but it'll actually show
you how you're wired as a person which
goes way deeper and will really be
helpful I'm also going to give you his
book from paycheck to purpose yes
because right now you're just doing this
for the paycheck trying to get out of
debt but what happens once you're out of
debt and you still don't like your job
and don't and that's the thing sometimes
you know you you do work a job that you
don't love or you work two jobs in this
case just to to get to an end point but
we don't want that to be where you stay
long term how much student loan debt do
you have
uh 68 000. and is that the extent after
that's done is that is that all the debt
or do you have more Beyond that's it
okay do you have any money in the bank
right now
um I have a thousand dollars saved cool
so if I'm you what I would start doing I
mean you're on the right step you got
your thousand dollar saved we're going
into baby step two you've already done a
great job getting rid of that 20K of
credit card debt you know in the
meantime I would be working as much as I
can because at thing one is getting this
debt paid off and while you're you're
doing three things simultaneously you're
working the 40 hours or however many
part-time hours at this 17 50 an hour
job as you can while you're doing that
you're reading paycheck to purpose while
you're doing that you're doing the get
clear assessment and hopefully you know
in the next oh two years or so we're out
of this debt and we are on track to a
new career something that you love
something that you know that you're
doing work that matters and you're going
in every day going I I get to work with
people I love this does that sound good
to you Tunisia that sounds good yeah
yeah and they're in the meantime there
may be a way for you to go hey I'm
making 49 now making 17.50 on the side
what if I could get a job that pays me
65 that I can do 40 hours a week and
then I can still do a side job and I
could really speed up this debt snowball
process getting rid of this debt now I
like that that gets me more excited for
you and that's exactly what I would be
doing I would be applying other places
other other research related roles that
I could step into now that I have some
experience where I could get paid more I
like that because there's definitely
side hustles that you can get that
you're making more than 17.50 an hour I
mean yeah you know what I'm saying look
at your skills look at are you able to
do any overtime with your current role
uh my main job yeah no okay so for a
capped out there let's start looking
updating the resume looking at other
jobs that could pay 60 70 to replace
that side income and then we can still
use the side income to get rid of the
debt faster let me ask you this is there
any is there any other place that we can
pull from to help you get out of this
debt what's your car situation
oh I I was in the studio
okay so we're not looking at that until
I'm not even I don't think it's wise
when you get a car right now and what
about so you said you live in the city
so I'm assuming that you've got high
rent or is there anywhere there that we
can I live
everything very little expenses yeah I
just paid 300 in rent okay look Tanisha
that's incredible keep keep going at it
keep doing what you're doing I like
George's idea of finding side hustles
that pay more so that you can go further
with your time make more money spend
less time I like that idea keep hacking
away at this debt the average person is
out of that debt snowball within 24 to
36 months and you're right on course for
that so keep going hang on the line
we'll get you that get clear career
assessment as well as the book from
paycheck to purpose all right let's go
to Jacob in Peoria Illinois Jacob
welcome to the show
oh thank you for taking my call last
question on a truck on a truck uh loan I
have all right I've always been someone
they speak directly on your phone for us
Jacob you're breaking up on us
yeah sorry about that it's all good is
this any better yes so you got the truck
loan
yeah I had a truck loan um for about
twelve thousand dollars paid for half
the truck took a loan on the other half
always I've never been a debt guy and I
just hate it um I don't have the cash to
pay it off right now
um but I do have a brokerage account
that has around 60 000 in it and it's
just single stocks that I've just
accumulated over the years
um and so I don't know if I should sell
off some of those all that's kind of
down right now
um so that's hard hard for me I just
wanted to kind of get some uh some of
your input on that yeah I mean when it
comes to the volatility of single stocks
as you now know
um I would cash out at least in the
amount of this truck loan and if you
want to hang on for a few months beyond
that and see what the rest does if you
can climb back up but long term I'm
cashing out of this thing and I'm
putting it into a less volatile
investment I'm putting it towards my
future do you have a fully funded
emergency fund
yes yep I do yeah I have a yes how much
do you have in savings right now
oh seven seven thousand so not much more
than
um not much more than just the six
months of expenses so if you cashed out
let's say 6 000 of those stocks uh and
six thousand from your savings that
would get you free and clear
out of this truck loan and then let's
say you cash out another 15 or 20 from
the stocks and you built that fully
funded emergency fund tomorrow
I love that I feel like you'd be
sleeping better at night having no
payments and having a pile of liquid
cash in the bank yeah
yeah that's a really good idea now you
just be aware you may have taxes on
those gains and so I would be working
with the tax Pro
yeah if I need to think through that as
well what's your income
uh my wife and I together we bring home
about a hundred and ten thousand awesome
year great income those stocks are is
that your only investment are you guys
also into 401ks or IRAs
yeah I have
I have a through work
on that so that I'm pretty good in that
area I feel like and my wife also she's
still in school she works part-time
um yeah I mean well with these single
stocks we usually say that with stocks
we don't want it to be more than like
five percent of your whole investment
picture so if there's a way I liked
George's idea of basically going back
and kind of working those steps in order
making sure you're out of debt first and
then you know pulling from those stocks
to refund uh your three to six months
and you know by then you'll probably put
that those stocks back to where they
need to be which is around five percent
of your net worth and you won't miss it
my friend you're gonna love debt Freedom
having liquid cash in the bank and
investing long term for your future and
those tax advantaged retirement accounts
and we can get to The Brokerage stuff
later and have some fun but right now
let's build this financial foundation
for Jacob and his family I love it man
thanks for the call more of that coming
up triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five well if
you're listening to the show you know
that we've all done stupid with money
around here Jade and I included and
sometimes it's fun to laugh about it and
the important thing is we don't make
that mistake again we grow we move on
that's right but uh there's this Yahoo
article Jade that I thought was kind of
hilarious kind of sad 17 things people
spend big money on that they're kicking
themselves over looking back so I wanted
to cover a few and get your takes yes
let's do it let's do it all right this
one was an interesting one someone said
a time share oh we already know about
that okay so this guy said I went to the
seminar for a three-night stay at a
beach resort and they got me they were
phenomenal salesmen but they lie out of
their beeps we spent thousands over
years only use the timeshare once we
hear that all the time George they only
use it look they almost got me one time
in Las Vegas dang I didn't know that's
what it was and I ended up on this bus
getting ready to go to wherever the
times yeah and then when I tried to get
off the bus they would not let me off
the bus George so I know how this guy
came in Jade's way that's a bold move I
had to get medieval on him so yeah this
person goes on to say they paid a lawyer
to get them out of the contract uh now
they're free these things are scams and
if you don't believe me uh how terrible
of an investment they are which by the
way you don't own anything so not really
invested in anything you can find them
on eBay for a dollar people are
desperately trying to get rid of them
well he's fortunate that he was able to
get out of his because it ain't easy let
me tell you all right here's another one
someone said I bought a mobile home as a
starter home no one ever explained to me
as a young adult the importance of
investment in future planning mobile
homes of course do not hold nor increase
in value so you never build equity it's
akin to renting except you have to cover
all of your own repair costs too it's a
terrible financial decision do not buy
mobile homes kids just don't do it good
advice there yeah it's going down in
value let's see I see this one down here
this is about credit cards George this
is you are my favorite favorite topic he
says I opened a credit card in college
bought something I don't even remember
what it was and completely forgot about
it I never got a statement and three
years later I suddenly have collections
agencies calling me non-stop over a
twenty dollar debt with hundreds of
collection fees it took me years to get
my credit back to not crappy levels wow
been there been there and we did it all
for the free t-shirt back in college
been there done that on the college how
is it even legal to let these people on
the college campus I don't know dude
gosh I we've all done it now here's one
I I have never done this is an
interesting one someone said I agreed to
take over my ex-girlfriend's bills so
that she could pay off her debts five
years and over a hundred thousand
dollars of my money later she was in
more debt than when we started and
cheating on me don't ever do this just
make her be an adult or a dumper it's
never worth it this is like this needs
to go on Mori or something yeah yeah
they need to be on um that is some drama
oh that's terrible ex-girlfriends I
can't think of one ex-girlfriend that I
want to give a dollar let alone cover
all of her bills you know what people
will do anything love is blind I think
when he was paying the bills they were
dating they were I think you're right I
think they were dating and then it came
back to bite him in the butt because
she's cheating on him after he's given
her six figures don't guys you don't yes
wine and dine your ladies but do not pay
their debts do not don't do it don't
co-sign please yikes that was a name
right there she she took advantage of
that homie yeah I don't dig that let me
let me let me read this one this one she
says uh financing a car and then leasing
a new one so she financed the used car
leased a new one never again I bought my
current car in a new light condition and
paid it in full with cash I love never
having to deal with I am with it I love
never having to deal with car payments
that's great once you get fleeced you
ain't never going back can I tell you
all a secret do you know that when I was
dating Sam he this this goes along with
this dumpster enough he bought my used
car we were we were engaged but I had a
car and he thought that I should have a
better car and he bought me a Jeep
Liberty and luckily when once we got
married we hoped snowball it together
these are bad choices people what a
romantic Samus I'm saying this to say
this is the dumb stuff we do nothing
says love like a financial transaction
like co-signing yeah right this one got
me someone said lending my credit card
to family
how few brain cells do you need to have
to trust your family with a credit card
it's like giving a kid just Monopoly
money
to go spend George I'm scared I'm scared
can I okay we gotta share our stupid
ones all right what's yours okay can I
tell you guys this is the dumbest thing
I've ever done because it was just extra
dumb I went to college George I had two
full score I had a full presidential
scholarship which means
everything paid for and I had a full
volleyball athletic scholarship wow my
bills were paid for college and do you
know that the financial aid folks talked
me into taking out student loans so that
I could pay for just life they said Jade
you're gonna need new clothes You're
Gonna Want after the games you're going
to want to go out to eat with your
friends and I took out student 1000
George
that's what I did lived it up in college
I don't remember it I remember going to
Walmart spending 60 on groceries just
like everybody else I don't know what
happened to the money that's nuts beat
that uh well I once shipped a pair of
Air Force Ones on Craigslist to a guy in
Nigeria because he said it was for his
cousin
and I S and this was not like a Nigerian
prince thing I listed my Air Force Ones
for sale a nice pair of shoes and I got
an email from a guy who seemed legit he
was like Hey I want to get this as a
gift to my cousin he lives in Nigeria
I'll pay you extra for shipping leaving
an extra 50 bucks and I was like sweet
and he was like hey I'll Pay Pal you
right now I got the email from PayPal
what that showed the transaction I went
great I'm gonna go ship these today
I went back a day later
the email from PayPal was not an email
from PayPal it was a forgery and I
clicked through the email address and
saw that it was all a lie the money
never actually hit my PayPal account and
these shoes were gone in Nigeria so this
is like a Nigerian homeboy yeah it's
like a Nigerian cousin and I felt I fell
for it now here's the crazy part the
shoes showed up six months later back at
my door and it said Return to Sender
what so whoever was running the scam it
must have been a bad address or I don't
know I don't know George that's
hilarious Air Force ones I love it
here's a crazy one though that we didn't
hit uh someone said not mine but my
dad's he bought 500 worth of collectible
Star Trek dinner plates in the 80s
thinking they'd be worth a ton of money
in a few years oh my gosh I feel like
someone else Beanie Babies
someone out there who's a big Star Trek
fan with some money they might be
willing to buy that I I might notice
some people I might know some people
who's willing to buy it not me
wow wow well here's the deal uh we've
all done stupid with money and we want
to hear your stories uh from our
listeners and so if you have a stupid
tax story where you made a financial
mistake you had some regrets and you're
okay with us laughing about it please
email us at ask ramseysolutions.com and
in the subject line put stupid tax ask
ramseysolutions.com subject line stupid
tax we'd love to hear it because I think
you know what it does it creates
some levity around money it makes it
more comfortable to admit our own
mistakes and everyone thinks they're
they've done the stupidest thing with
money and then you read another story
and you go nope yeah George everybody
has done something stupid with money
it's the people who refuse to admit it
that's still broke oh it's the people
who refused it because if you can't
admit it that means you haven't learned
and if you refuse to change that even
better you do stupid over and over again
that's a choice yeah yeah you got to
start learning from these mistakes
ouch so here's the good news I stopped
doing stupid when I saw through this
broken system that was meant to keep me
broke I went through Financial Peace
University you did this as well this was
like 10 years ago now and I became so
much more aware of my money how other
people were trying to get my money what
I could be doing with my money and it
gave me such peace and confidence
because I realized oh I don't have to be
the smartest guy in the room I just have
to do a budget and stay out of debt
that's so true it's the simple things
George it's you know I think think money
culture tries to make us think it's so
complex and it's only for the wealthy
and it's only for certain people yeah
then there's the dude Bros but it's
those simple things living on less than
you make
getting on a budget can you believe it
paying off your debt who knew easy easy
can be hard but it don't have to be
smart to do smart stuff with money and
that's very encouraging for people like
me and me wow that's good stuff well hey
more of your calls maybe more of your
stupid tax coming up right here on the
Ramsey Show triple eight eight two five
five two two five
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show if you've been
wondering can I build wealth even in
this economy we've got some answers for
you there is a ton of noise out there
right now with inflation and massive
layoffs and Rising interest rates and we
understand that you're fearful and you
want some hope and that's why we're
coming to a city near you with our
Building Wealth live event Dave Ramsey
and our team of Ramsay personalities
will be doing this Building Wealth live
spring tour where we dig into all of the
Hot Topics that you're wondering about
we give you a proven plan to build
wealth and keep it even in this economy
that is the guarantee right there
and each one is going to have its own
Flair and unique lineup so in
Indianapolis on February 16th it'll be
Dave myself Rachel Cruz and Jade on
February the 23rd will be in Austin
Texas it'll be Dave Ken Dr John deloney
and Jade then we'll be in Salt Lake City
on April 24th where you can see Dave
Rachel myself and Christina Ellis and
for our last stop we've got Anaheim on
May 2nd with Dave Ken Dr John and
Christina so we're switching it up and
so I'll miss you all in Austin and
Anaheim but we'd love to see you if
you're near one of those cities you can
get there it is going to be a good time
tickets start at just 49 bucks or you
can get a four pack starting at 175. so
bring some friends borrow some if you
have to it's going to be a good time go
to ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats today
now exciting yeah I can't wait I'm just
elated about this tour it's been so fun
the crowds have been electric yeah and
it gives me hope too because if you just
watch the headlines you're like oh gosh
this is all going going south real quick
yeah and then you meet these people and
they're like oh yeah we became baby
steps millionaires this year we paid off
all our debt this year Yes we finally
save for that big down payment goal we
had you're like it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be you surround yourself with hope
that's right dealers check your input
check your inputs are they the right
ones you need to have in your life let's
go to the phone Scott is up next in
Corpus Christi Texas Scott welcome to
the Ramsay show
thank you what's going on
well I called just a CNN if I get some
advice if I'm making a correct decision
on constructing our new home uh in
today's uh economy what's got you
worried
uh just investing uh right now our uh
the home uh is for 566 000.
um with a six percent interest rate
uh on a 15-year fix which would put my
uh principal and interest uh at 4 700 a
month
but my my goal is to pay the house off
at a five-year point
and to do that I will need to uh
take you know pretty much
what I've been putting into savings to
do you know to pay that off in five
years
what's your income
my income is 240 000 a year
um I'm guessing you don't have any debt
Scott I I have zero dead zero Consumer
Debt
um
and uh have you been contributing uh I'm
guessing you have a decent savings three
to six months I have uh we have 104 104
000 utilities and I'm guessing you've
been contributing 15 to
retirement maybe even more
yeah that that's my question because we
have I have not been putting anything
into retirement or Investments okay and
my uh individual contractor
so I've been
taking really what I would invest and
paying college tuition for my kids
so that's where that money has gone so I
have you know right now zero retirement
okay so I love that you want to pay off
this home loan so early however you know
when working the baby steps we suggest
you do baby steps four five and six
simultaneously but also in order so you
kind of skipped ahead and you went to
baby step five and we're funding the
kids the kids college and now you're
trying to skip ahead again and get to
six and start paying off your home early
but it's you know you got to get to the
retirement because here's the thing
you're going to retire regardless the
kids may or may not go to college you
know you got to make sure you've got
that money um sitting aside for
retirement now you mentioned your you've
got your own business or you're an
independent contractor uh you may I want
you to get with a smartvester pro
because they're probably going to want
to get you into solo 401k or some sort
of sep situation set up so that you can
start putting aside money for retirement
and in your case I would start with the
15 percent and then if you have money
above that then you can start paying off
the mortgage early
so it sounds like the you know at the
rate that you were hoping to pay off
this this home and because of uh your
income here you you have enough money to
do all three of those things to invest
the 15 if you decide to go with the sep
uh the contribution is going to come
from the employer side and they can
you'd be able to contribute up to 25 of
whatever you take in salary or if you
decide to go the solo 401K route you can
contribute either as the employer or the
employee which is nice but like I said
get set up with a smartvester pro you
can go on our site at Ramsey Solutions
and find that but that's thing one and
then after that you're gonna find that
you probably do have extra money in your
budget to start chugging away and paying
off that Home Mortgage early what do you
think George Well Scott are you saying
the loan is going to be 566 or is that
the home
price no the the price to construct uh
the house I I don't have the mortgage
yet uh because we're we're going to
build uh my land is paid off
um so the the build price uh that I
would Finance is 566. okay so I'm
wondering can we slow down just a touch
save up more to put down so that we can
get that mortgage uh that loan lower
because right now I mean 4 700 a month
is your take-home pay close to 15
uh my technical pay is is right at
twenty thousand it is at 20. okay so
that 240 is your take home
correct great well that will leave you
with a whole bunch of margin to still
pay those off early and as long as
you're able to cash flow you know
college and you're putting that 15 away
anything beyond that will help you get
there and the kids you know they're
going to be through college in the next
four years that sounds like
uh I have uh one that's not in college
yet
um
right yeah one right now that's uh that
two years left okay well I would get
this played spinning because we want you
to start getting the power of compound
interest working in your favor and those
retirement accounts and while getting
that house paid for is an awesome goal
you're gonna get there and if you do it
in six years instead of five right big
whoop you are so far ahead of most
Americans are you already a millionaire
net worth
no okay so that would be my goal for you
before retirement let's make sure we've
got a nest egg plugging away growing for
us and we have money in the bank we've
got a paid for house which is going to
lower all of your expenses in retirement
and that will put you on the path to
retire with dignity how old are you
I am 53. okay yeah that's great you're
going to do just fine you know the
average person who has a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage they're paying that off
just in a little over 10 to 11 years so
no matter what you're going to pay this
thing off early and you're going to go
into retirement without without a home
payment which is ultimately the goal oh
yeah and I mean you've got a fabulous
income Scott and so that gives me great
peace now if you were making a hundred
thousand and you had a five thousand
dollar mortgage payment I would be in
tears for you and that would be
frightening but as long as you think
that income will stay at 240 or above
and you can sustain that for the next
you know five to ten years as you get
this stuff paid off and start working on
retirement and then start just plugging
as much money away as you can so that
you're not having to work at 65. that's
right which is most people so you're in
good shape way to go that gave me a
great joy to take that call I love that
again it's the choices he was a little
out of whack with the baby steps and
that's okay his income is great he's
thought this through it was just kind of
you know well and he's crunching the
numbers most people go into and go I'm
going to do a 30 year with as little
down as possible and I'll just pay it
off over 30 years and I'm going dude why
do you want to hang on debt for three
more decades you know that's one of
those conversations George I just that's
the big ticket thing is oh I want to
have the 30-year mortgage and then I
have more spending power and I can
leverage my spending power I just that
ain't it cause think about it at the end
of the day there's still 63 percent of
people living paycheck to paycheck the
people who say that they're going to
take that extra savings and invest it
they don't do it nope don't tell me you
will because I know human behavior the
stats tell us George I'm gonna go for
the Oreos before the kale it's just how
we are as humans it's how we are so I'd
rather force that decision than go I got
a 15 year now let's pay it off like a
five that's right Scott's doing it that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books my thanks to Jade warshaw all the
folks in the booth and new America will
be back real soon
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell hosting
with my good friend Jade warshaw this
hour and we want to hear from you give
us a call with your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
AAA
825-5225 Andrew kicks us off in San Jose
Andrew welcome to the show
thank you what's going on
so I'm having a really hard time getting
behind the idea of dropping my savings
down to a thousand dollars and trying to
pay off some debt I have okay
how much debt do you have
uh well I have two car uh payments one
of them is about twenty four thousand
the other one's about 72. oh I hope your
income is just baffling blow us away
what is it
uh my income is I think I made around
210 000 last year okay I feel better I
do feel better okay you're so you got
two car loans what else
that's it
so I'll say that obviously but do you
need to do you need both cars is there
another person in the picture here
oh my wife your wife has one eye or the
other okay and are you guys combining
finances so is that all of the debt
between the two of you that's all she
says at home I I work so tell us more
about this this issue with the the
emergency fund the thousand dollars
saved so my guess is you have a bunch of
money in liquid cash right now how much
do you have
uh I have about 42 000 okay
and you want to get on the Ramsay plan
you're my biggest issue with it is is
that going under a thousand to me is
just scary especially when you have
random bills and expenses good example
for me is I had a dishwasher go out in
December and I had a fence all over in
the last couple days just to me going
down to that low is just
I I don't know if I can personally do
that or not well here's the thing it's
not it's not it's temporary it's not for
the long haul this is a very uh
temporary action so that it lights your
butt on fire so that you get this debt
paid off super fast and in your
situation you've got a great income
you've got money saved there's no reason
that you can't get out of debt very
quickly to where that thousand dollar
emergency fund is a distant memory and
pretty soon you're going to be up to
having three to six months of savings so
it's not intended to be a long-term fix
and the reason we say that is because it
you know many people can make the
argument George that oh a thousand
dollars it's not enough what happens if
this happens or what happens if that
happens but the fact is 36 of Americans
have no money saved and those who have a
little bit of money saved they don't
have a thousand dollars 56 percent of
Americans could not pay for a thousand
dollar emergency so Andrew that's why we
have it set up that way
um it's it's multi-purpose so in this
case you you knowing that you've got a
family you knowing these things you're
going to work even faster and be more
intent about getting out of debt and
here's the thing it's a thousand dollar
emergency fund but if something were to
happen you still have your normal
monthly cash flow right it's not to say
that you wouldn't be able to add more
money to that in order to make a repair
or make something happen I can tell you
from firsthand experience it took us
seven and a half years to get out of
debt we had 460 000 dollars of debt
Andrew we had a thousand dollar
emergency fund and you want to know what
happened we'd use it and then we'd have
to replace it then we use it again and
have to replace it that's I mean that's
what it's there for and if it was
something that cost a little bit more
than what we'd have to do is we'd have
to sell something or find a way to get
that money and we always could
and I think that you'll be surprised at
how well that thousand dollars serves
you
and even for my area uh which is
generally a bit more than most it's a
thousand is still sufficient what do you
find yep well it was never meant to be
sufficient because truthfully we go well
it should be 15 it should be three
thousand it should be six thousand yeah
you could say I mean a new roof is more
than five thousand so we should let's
make it ten thousand right so part of it
is to get people started on the plan
obviously you have an incredible income
and so let's just do some napkin math
here you said you've got 42 in savings
so if you took that down to one that
means you can throw forty one thousand
dollars at that ninety six thousand of
debt which means the first car is paid
off and now you free up a payment and
you're left with 55 000 left right now
you make two uh two hundred ten thousand
dollars you could throw probably ten
thousand dollars a month at this debt
right
give or take the one thing I would say
is I get paid bi-weekly so technically
speaking I'm missing a portion of that
because I get two extra payments one
with a few different months sure so it's
slightly different is how that works out
but roughly each month you could
probably throw about 10K and so this
debt is if you do the Ramsey plan in
five months you're completely debt free
and then those next few paychecks
restock that emergency fund back up to
Thirty forty thousand dollars and so
we're talking a period of six to eight
months to do all of this that's right if
you get gazelle intents now the other
side is here would be is it might be a
little bit longer than that because you
have a mortgage payment to also take
into account into it okay
and it's a reasonable mortgage
for your take-home pay
uh that's three thousand uh a month is
my current mortgage which everyone tells
me is good yeah I mean your take-home
pays is what about 12 or more 15. yeah
it varies from yeah it's not 12 to 15.
California taxes they'll get you then
you're fine you're fine as far as the
percentage
I mean think about what saying if you
take that savings you knock out that
first car payment uh 24K how much was
the car how much is the car payment on
the car that's got the
that's worth 24 000.
uh the content is 500 a month you're
freeing up 500 a month right there just
right there if you had an emergency
suddenly you have fifteen hundred
dollars not just a thousand do you see
what I'm saying so it's kind of like
understanding that the thousand dollars
is there but you still have your income
you still have the money that you're
budgeting every month and there's always
something that you can cut down slim
back whenever you know if Murphy does
come into your house
a new budget this year I definitely have
little room in my budget to pay more for
things so that's fine yeah no I think I
think that the baby steps works for
everybody you know everybody you know
it's fine to have questions about it and
we're happy to answer those questions
but I want you to go into this Andrew
knowing that this is the proven method
this is the smartest way to do it and in
your case like like George said you're
going to be out of this in six to eight
months
okay yeah let's go do it like Jay said
if something happens you get another
fence that falls down well we're just
gonna pause the baby steps and go all
right the next paycheck goes towards
replacing the fence that's right and uh
you don't lose any sleep over it and so
that's the the truth about the thousand
dollars is it's not as big of an issue
as people make it out to be because you
have future cash flow coming in that's
right and it's okay if you pause and you
know something else I like about the
thousand dollars saved George is it
forces you to calm down
to pause and think about your actions
because a lot of times something
unexpected happens and we think we got
to do it now you know and you start
spending this money you put on a credit
card you pull your savings but you want
to know what if your washer and dryer
breaks do you know what you'll be okay
you'll be okay for a while you don't
have to go to Home Depot that night and
replace it you don't even have to go
that week you want to know what I did I
drove over to my mother-in-law's house I
did my laundry over there until we had
the money that's what makes you wait it
makes you think
and I think we have the illusion of
safety when we have a pile of money in
the bank but yet we owe A lender ninety
six thousand dollars with interest it's
a facade I feel a whole lot safer
getting rid of that and uh being back in
control of my greatest wealth building
tool my income I love it we're rooting
for you Andrew thanks for the call man
good call this is the is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour our question of the day comes from
Jake in Maryland here's what Jake has to
say I've been dating my girlfriend for
three years and she's in her first year
of med school she'll have over three
hundred thousand dollars of student loan
debt by the time she graduates I'm
planning to propose to her after I
graduate and get a good paying job a
year from now I'm 24 and I'll graduate
debt free with a finance degree later
this year I've got 20 000 in savings and
I'm wondering if I should use that and
the income I'll have for my future job
to help pay for her med school since her
debt will be mine once we get married I
don't like debt and 300 000 just feels
overwhelming to me I don't know if it's
a good plan to pursue and my parents
don't think I should do it since we're
not married yet I I was initially
planning to use my savings to put a down
payment on a house once I graduate and
get a job I would like to get a second
opinion on this we'll give you that we
might give you a third one yeah we'll
give you some opinions Jake here's the
deal
until you're and this is for everybody
until you're married we don't suggest
combining finances we don't suggest
paying for your girlfriends this paying
for your boyfriends that even if your
fiance status we don't we don't suggest
going to that level because here's the
thing you don't know if it's going to
work out and if it doesn't work out and
you've dropped you know the 20K that
you've painstakingly saved you know for
a home down payment man you're up a
creek and you're feeling you're feeling
terrible at that point now let's talk
about this 300K in student loan debt
let's just pretend George that that
everything goes right that in a year
from now he's able to graduate he pops
the question she says yes and they get
married let's say that happens a year
from now then and only then he could
start talking they could start talking
about okay how are we gonna pay this
debt off together but until then it's
simply just a conversation they can
start plotting out they can make sure
they're on the same page moving forward
and that's probably where you need to
start Jake is having some conversations
with her because she you you're not okay
with debt but she was okay with taking
out three hundred thousand dollars of
debt and uh you guys need to have a
conversation about that because if she's
okay with debt and you're not then uh
you guys are gonna run into some
friction ahead now I would advise this
if she hasn't already taken out the
student loans because you said she's got
a couple of years until she graduates
let's try to convince her to pay cash
and pay as she goes slow down a little
bit see if she can find some programs
that will help supplement her education
so that she's not having to go into the
student loan debt there is always a way
to pay for school and we have a Ramsay
personality here Christina Ellis she
specializes in that George she was able
to earn over five hundred thousand
dollars in scholarships and went to
amazing schools Vanderbilt man she's way
smarter than me yeah so I'm telling you
there is a way to do this I think you
need to have that conversation but I do
not I repeat I do not want you spending
your money on her education especially
now in this boyfriend girlfriend Zone
definitely not in the fiance Zone not
until you get married what do you think
George well the end of the question was
I want to use my savings for a down
payment on a house once I graduate and
get a job and the truth is if you plan
on marrying her this could delay that
dream good point and that stinks and
that's one thing that debt does to your
life it delays your dreams and if you
don't believe me go watch borrow the
future and hear the numerous stories
about how student loans have held people
back from becoming homeowners getting
married from having kids and it's
heartbreaking and so I would suggest you
two sit down and watch that together and
you can help her develop a plan to try
to graduate debt free but don't put a
dime towards it and I would pause on
this home purchase until we know more
are we gonna get married because Lord
knows she's going to want to move
somewhere else and you didn't pick the
right place yeah and the wall color is
not the right one and so I would just
put pause on this keep saving up that
down payment have the emergency fund in
place you keep living your life debt
free and have those values conversations
around money that's right thanks for the
question good stuff all right let's go
to the phones Mason is waiting for us in
Indianapolis Mason welcome to the Ramsay
show
hello hey what's going on
um well I'm looking at buying a truck
all right
and I'm also looking at buying a house
but it will be a flipping house so I
want to make some money off of it
um I'm wondering though if I should buy
this twelve thousand dollar truck
uh which is kind of it's towards the top
of my budget or if I should buy a less
nice truck
for like seven Grand or something like
that what's your income
my income I'm making I'm paid by the
hour I'm getting 17 an hour and I'm
usually getting 2 200 2 500 in that
range every month okay so between twenty
two hundred and twenty two yeah
how old are you
I'm 19. where'd you hear about all this
house flipping stuff
um well I work construction with my
grandpa it's really just me and him uh
doing our own kind of business and I
guess it was from him
okay well you know I'm I'm in the boat
of focusing on our primary residence for
you first and getting that paid off and
later on down the road we can become you
know Real Estate Investors but at your
age I would focus on you know what does
my future look like how do I get my
income up are you debt free
how much money do you have saved
twenty seven thousand oh awesome and
part of that's your emergency fund
yeah I guess so I don't really
I don't know I'll figure that out later
I don't know how much we'll figure it
out right now take take a month of your
expenses and multiply it out let's call
it by four months what does that add up
to okay
probably 10 12 Grand
that's a big emergency fund I was
thinking five thousand whoa well do you
not have any expenses are you renting
right now what are you doing
no uh well I live with my parents okay
and I
uh so that's one expense taken care of I
do have a phone bill uh so that's 50
bucks and then I I don't pay insurance
I'm with that on my uh dad and I don't
have truck payments or car payments or
insurance but I am going to pick that up
once I
uh buy this truck and have insurance
payments so based on my estimate if
you're working full-time you're probably
making right now about 27 to 30 thousand
dollars
and so I wouldn't spend more than that
12 for a truck you've got the money I
want you to do this in cash Don't Go
Near a car loan they're going to try to
sell you on one when you walk into that
dealership wherever you go to buy it
don't fall for it so I would start
looking for a 12 000 truck if that's
what you need if you don't need a 12 000
truck get something cheaper I'd rather
you have more money for your future
goals like a down payment
okay
so and I would focus on a primary
residence for you first you're only 19
man you're so far ahead of the game
already that's right so imagine what
happens if we can double your income
what kind of work are you doing right
now
uh construction right now we're working
remodeling a funeral home cool and
you're working with your grandpa
is it his business
yeah and he kind of just owns the job
it's not a like a company are you going
to take this over one day or are you
just wanting to do your own thing
uh it doesn't really matter if I take
his company or not and we're not that
big it's kind of a word of mouth
business
uh potentially but I would rather make
my money through real estate yeah I like
what George is saying I think that we do
this right and we do it in the right
order and it seems like for you you know
the truck is right on track you know
it's it's right in line with what you're
earning so it's not it's not overboard
but after that you know you're living at
home your expenses are low save up and
save up to buy whatever you're doing
with either a very large down payment or
in your situation you're a young guy you
might be able to save out save up and
eventually buy something outright in
cash
yeah I mean I I was 32 before I spent
more than six thousand dollars on a car
yeah yeah and so you got plenty of time
and you're not doing anything
irresponsible here by going um I need a
truck for work and I'm trying to spend
12 Grand now that's gonna be an older
truck it may not be fancy but it'll you
know transport your materials just fine
and so the part of the emergency fund
now is what happens when something
happens to the truck and what happens
when you're on your own and you're
you're renting or you're a homeowner and
you've got to cover the big bills like
the HVAC goes out and so that's why we
want you to have a fully funded
emergency fund but man you're doing
great sure 27k in the bank at 19 with no
debt wanting to continue a debt-free
life this kid's gonna be okay I just
love that he called us I love that these
19 years
I don't know what I was doing in 19 I
was a knucklehead at 19 I was
Couchsurfing I was sleeping on I was
sleeping on a friend's couch we lived in
the apartment and there were no rooms
left so I got to sleep on the couch
[Music]
no more couch life took control over
money that's what it's all about we're
pulling for you Mason more of your calls
coming up triple eight eight two five
five two two five right here on the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this is the Ramsey Show and on
the debt free stage we've got some
special guests with us Jim and Debbie
are here how are you guys we're doing
great how are you we are so glad to have
you where you guys from
in Buckeye Arizona that sounds wonderful
I've been there wow really that's a fun
fact fun fact I never heard of it well
we're glad you made the Trek to
Nashville to celebrate your debt-free
journey with us how much did you pay off
708 719.60
bewildered is the only word for that
okay how long did that take 32 months
wow okay now I'm extra older I have so
many questions a lot of stupid tax in
there George trust me what was your
range of income during that time
averaged 180 000. okay okay there is so
much to unpack here Jim and Debbie yes
tell us how this happened what got you
on this journey how did you get here
today well we got started in uh 2020
with the pandemic uh we took Financial
Peace University at our church we've got
to give a shout out to our coordinators
James and Charlotte Green and our
pastors Ron and Sue Rockwell at Harvest
Church in Peoria Arizona all right took
the class and I'm not really sure but it
just clicked for us we were sick and
tired of being sick and tired and we
just knew we had to get out of the mess
we created so you had almost three
quarters of a million of debt what kind
of debt was this we had about we had 150
000 in Consumer Debt between IRS credit
cards a lot of stupid tax we had a piece
of property in there
just credit cards maxed out and just a
bunch of it started with 150 what's the
rest well then we have our we're
self-employed for fire protection
contractors in Arizona with a backflow
Plumbing side and we have a business so
that had an industrial condo and we had
a mortgage on okay and then we had our
personal residence so we've also paid
off our house
thank goodness gracious what a 180.
we're happy to be weird I'll tell you
what was the mortgage worth 300
000. wow what's your personal residence
worth today uh last we checked Zillow
was about 650. oh my goodness my
goodness are you guys baby steps
millionaires we're close we're we're on
the two we're on the short side of the
uh of the retirement side so we got some
catching up to do there but now we got a
lot oh yeah and a big shovel
once that stock market comes back yep
you guys will be right there oh that's
so exciting
smartvestor Pro in Arizona already he's
been guiding us the last year and a half
so we're on track that's incredible so
how does it feel I mean you've paid
everything off you don't have a payment
in the world I mean how long has it been
by the way since you paid off that final
debt July uh 11th of 22. oh wow so
you're just out here living yes ma'am
you get that money and it's your money
how does that feel tell the people how
it feels
wonderful
um I just had to share with Jim here a
while ago that even when you have your
mortgage payment that's a clue to pay
your electric bill the light bill okay
honesty here I have been late a couple
months because no mortgage you forgot
about the bills you know what for that
I'm not mad at that transparency you
know I love that she's the money does
not matter so much that I am not even
thinking about it I forgot about it turn
the water off again I'm not mad Jim
Debbie I'm confused here the numbers
don't add up tell us how you paid off
seven hundred and eight thousand in 32
months that's a good question well we
just have a big shovel fortunately and
we worked a lot of extra hours did you
sell stuff well we did we sold the
industrial condo that the business uh
was was releasing from and with the
proceeds from that we paid off the home
mortgage and the and the so what were
the net profits you used to throw at the
debt from that industrial condo well how
much of the 708 was the sale
560. wow I love it I love it and so
another you know 150 or so that was all
you guys hustling grinding sacrificing
using your income and putting it to good
use we hit the ground running in March
of 20 and we didn't stop till December
of 20 and we worked ungodly amount of
hours we just we were just working all
the time and we didn't have a side
hustle our side hustle was our extra
business work that we could create
through the inspection work that we do
and we just piled it on just put the
work in I saw on my screen there's bags
of coins tell me tell me what's up with
the coins what these bags of quarters
are please after the class you know they
talk about getting your thousand dollar
in the emergency fund well we have a
five gallon jug of at home of change
that we would just throw in there but we
got so excited we went home and emptied
out the jug that night didn't go to bed
till like two in the morning just
sitting out the piles all over the place
wow I love this I am in love that is
some Next Level sacrifice right there it
really is dude this is a lesson to all
the people don't don't be afraid to
count that change now the coins count in
all that sounds shocking how fast it
adds up for sure I bet so you guys were
clearly running your business kind of
leveraging some debt and to run this
thing are you now running the business
debt free as well yes we are wow oh does
that change the decisions you make oh
man yes it does big time that's
incredible it's funny when you have debt
and think about your dollar where it's
going but now since you're out of debt
it's like okay where's that going to why
is it going there and you know you
protect it a little bit better yeah when
your business is in a much safer place
we saw with the pandemic somebody got
wiped out because they were leveraged
out their eyeballs yeah and the ones
that were running with cash went all
right we got money in the bank we don't
owe people money we're going to be safe
we kind of stumbled on that in the
pandemic because we thought it was going
to shut us down as well but with all the
commercial properties not being open
they got a lot more of the work done
repair stuff done so that became an
opportunity for us wow and we just
capitalized on it big time that's so
great so tell me what's the plan now
you've paid off all your debt you worked
like maniacs you saved up the coins what
is the plan now how are you guys
celebrating this well we've done this
today is our 35th wedding anniversary oh
my goodness congratulations thank you so
I was going to say what's the secret to
getting out of debt but what's the
secret to 35 years of marriage
Mary is strong God-fearing woman let's
go trust her baby let's go I still got a
long way to go there but that's the
secret ever been debt free in 35 years
of being married we have not wow never
this is New Territory this is a new
frontier New Frontier for sure so what
do you do you're here to celebrate
obviously is there anything else I mean
you're here in Nashville what else we
did we've done a couple of trips we went
to Wisconsin and gave my dad a surprise
85th birthday party last year and we've
done some travel to Colorado this past
year and got some furniture for the
house I've got a barbecue island going
in when we get home so y'all better live
like no one else you know the barbecue
island is the new American dream I'm
getting for men out there should be for
what it costs goodness gracious well we
are so proud of you guys we're honored
to have you happy anniversary yes we're
gonna we're gonna give you an
anniversary gift today it's the live and
give box that includes Dave's
best-selling books The Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires that's
the next chapter for you as well as a
year of Financial Peace University Maybe
to go back through it again take a
friend with you maybe give it away and
get someone else started on their
journey is there one other thing that I
can share please please it was this was
a scripture that came on early on in the
journey for us and it really ministered
to me a lot and especially in the hard
times it's Ecclesiastes 11 6. it says in
the morning sow your seed and that
evening withhold not your hand for you
do not know which will prosper this or
that whether both alike will be good um
oh my goodness well what an incredible
story you guys have accomplished so much
in 32 months and it's a great reminder
that it's it's never too late even after
35 years of marriage the old dogs can
learn new tricks and I'm talking about
Jim Debbie's as young as ever you guys
right George yeah all right we've got
Jim and Debbie from Arizona 708 thousand
dollars paid off in 32 months making 180
selling the industrial condo off the
business to help clear this deck count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
ready three two one we're dead free
oh
and just like that another one bites the
dust almost three quarters of a million
dollars and they just decided they just
decided these folks don't have business
debt they don't have a mortgage George
it's just such a great reminder that in
today's world you can decide you can
decide they went 35 years of marriage
and never were debt-free until this
moment wow that's powerful can you
believe that you have the choice to
America you could be the next Jim and
Debbie regardless of your age regardless
of how much debt you have you can do
this stuff but it has to start today
with your I've had it moment you go I
don't want to live like this any longer
my future is too important for me to
stay in debt given my money to lenders
every month I want to build a legacy I
want to build a future and that is how
it's done Amazing Story they're Heroes
Jim and Debbie all are heroes I'm proud
of you guys this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour well about this year on the Ramsey
show we get flooded with calls because
everyone's looking for a fresh start
with their money especially after a
tough couple of years so if that's you
you can't wish for things to change and
expect it to happen you've got to do
some things differently with your money
and you've got to have a plan and we can
teach you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you will learn step by step
how to pay off debt and how to build
wealth and nearly 10 million people have
taken FPU now they followed this plan
they've changed their lives it works
don't try to reinvent this and when you
intentionally follow this plan with
Focus intensity this year will be
different you'll have more peace in your
finances and in your life so get started
today go to ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com slash FPU
John is up next in Dayton Ohio John
welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on
um I wanted to call I'm about uh 34 000
in debt
um 14 000 through a personal loan eleven
thousands on a credit card and then I
owe nine thousand to a family member
um I kind of took the personal loan out
in a panic and um just want to see what
your guys's opinion is on it on what I
can do with that what was the Panic
about
uh just to pay off the money that I owed
so you don't owe family anymore you do
I do owe the family uh 9 000 still okay
so it only paid off some of what you
owed the family
yes interesting okay what's your income
um together with my wife is our
take-home is about 75 000.
great
okay so what's your question today
basically the personal loan has um a
pretty high interest rate and
um I took one out without really knowing
much about it so I'm trying to see
basically what my options are with that
what's the interest rate um
uh 14
ouch yeah that's painful and what about
the credit cards what's the interest
right there um 25.
so I'm taking it that you don't have any
money saved up otherwise you probably
wouldn't have done this loan but do you
have any money saved anywhere
um we have about 1500 saved okay 1500.
you know I
this was my situation John I would just
walk it down through the baby steps and
I would I mean that's that's going to be
your quickest most efficient way out of
debt so we start with baby step one
which is getting that thousand dollars
saved you've already got fifteen hundred
so let's keep a thousand of it and then
we're gonna roll the next 500 into our
debt snowball now I know you're
concerned about these interest rates but
the way we do the debt snowball and the
way the debt snowball works is you list
the payments from smallest to largest
and the reason that we do that is so
that you can get a win quicker so that
you can feel the the excitement of that
win and so that will motivate you to
keep going and in this case I think
that's actually going to serve you well
because that first debt on your list is
family and obviously you're trying to
get that knocked out because you were
willing to take out a loan at 14 so
let's let's keep it like that let's
let's hit that that that family loan
with everything that we've got we're
going to take any we're gonna pay
minimum payments on everything but we're
gonna take any and all money that we can
find and as quickly as possible this
might be working more hours this might
be selling things things we have got to
get this debt paid off
um is it possible that you and your wife
could pick up some extra income here or
there
um yes yeah so I'm doing that you know I
think that with you guys's income thirty
four thousand dollars of debt you guys
should be clear of this I think you
could probably do this if you really
whittled this budget down are you guys
on a budget
um we actually just started this week
okay great great that's going to be the
secret sauce man because once you get on
the budget you're going to start seeing
all the ways that you can give yourself
a raise you're going to see all the ways
that you've been maybe overspending a
little bit areas where you've gotten a
little bit flabby that you can tighten
up on and I you know the average person
who starts working the baby steps
they're out within you know 24 to 36
months I definitely think for you guys
it's going to be closer to 18 to 24
months you can do this I think you could
do this in a year if you get intense and
you pick up some side work and you start
shaving down those expenses because
you're doing the budget you're looking
around paying attention going yeah we
could cut that for now and that Bill's a
little let's finish off the insurance
let's start shopping at a different
grocery store it's amazing how much
money you'll just find that's you start
doing that budget so is that was that
kind of how you saw this John was I can
be debt free within a year or so
yeah that's what we were trying to
trying to aim for was at least about a
year oh good and the way you'll get
there is using that debt snowball which
means that high interest loan is just
hanging out it's the last one you're
gonna tackle isn't it that personal loan
yes and that hurts
let that fuel your fire though let that
let that 14 feel you you attack the high
interest one first and what happens is
you kind of get comfortable and you go
slower but when that's just hanging out
there 25 interest on the credit card 14
of the person Alone number one you're
never going to touch debt again because
you felt the sting of that as the
interest racked up and you realize these
lenders are not my friend they weren't
doing me a favor by letting me go
fourteen thousand dollars into debt in a
panic without even explaining to me how
this will work I'll tell you what else
once you start changing grocery stores
and you have to cut that budget you guys
are working more you you talk about
feeling the sting George that'll make
you feel it when you thought your work
day was done for the day but then it's
time to clock into the next job
I'm doing this for a year or no longer
and whatever it takes we're getting rid
of this debt never again John I'm gonna
gift you one year of every dollar
premium which will help you uh get
control of that money it'll connect to
your bank account bring all the
transactions in we've got a paycheck
planning tool as part of that so how
hang on the line Austin will pick up and
we'll gift you one year of every dollar
premium awesome all right let's move on
to Troy in Topeka Kansas Troy welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello what's going on
um I am currently me and my wife are
trying to figure out we're trying to get
back on track with our money um I went
through financial peace like five years
ago with her
and now we're trying to get back on
track I took a loan out myself and it's
about fourteen hundred dollars
and it feels like I've been paying on
the last six months and it I'm just
ready to get rid of it I have other debt
on top of that so I'm wondering should I
start with this loan so I can get it out
of the way
um because this loan is taking money out
of my account if I don't make that
payment it will pull that money payment
out of there the minimum payment
yeah the minimum what's the minimum
payment on that
it's about 190 and what other debt every
half weeks
and then I have a my car payment which
is
I pay that every two weeks as well how
much is that what's the loan total
the car loan is 16 000.
okay what else do you have
and then I just have other small debts I
have uh 600 in credit card debt uh-huh
and then
just some Hospital debt what's that
which I I'm still trying to figure all
that one out I don't know 100 right now
all right so this is very similar to the
the previous call
yes when you're working the debt
snowball we want to list these debts
from smallest to largest and when we do
that we're still making minimum payments
on all the debt right because we don't
trust me you do not want debt collectors
calling you that is the most annoying
thing it takes a toll on your
self-confidence you want to keep those
guys out of your hair so do make minimum
payments are you able to make minimum
payments while still throwing money at
the debt snowball what's your income
um I make approximately 38
000 a year my wife just
um quit her job because really her
paycheck was just going to daycare okay
what was he staying at home now
she's in yeah she's gonna be a
stay-at-home mom
um for now she's gonna try to find
um she does baking she bakes so she's
gonna try to sell some products like
while baking okay just to make some
extra cash yeah and what are you doing
to bring in some extra money because
right now you got you guys got to pull
up that income so we can make this
snowball work does she have a car too
she does not she drives my car I have a
company vehicle so I drive that most of
the time she drives the other vehicle
what's your car worth
um what's it where I don't know what
it's worth okay my my feeling is we
might need to sell this car yeah if it's
worth 16
my guess is
now you're gonna need some money to buy
something used but if you if you can get
let's say you can sell the car for 20
you owe 16 and that leaves you with four
thousand dollars to go get a clunker
which you're not driving around much
right
right it's most of the company vehicle
so that can help speed this whole
process up and so we start attacking the
smallest debt first probably that credit
card then we're going after that
personal loan the medical debt and then
you could be debt free soon even making
38k but I'd try to pick up some extra
outside jobs bring in some extra income
to speed this whole thing up and that
might look like selling the car and if
you have any savings laying around
that's over a thousand K drain that down
to a thousand and put that money towards
your debt snowball you guys can do this
appreciate the call Troy that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Jade warshaw all
the folks in the booth and you America
thanks for tuning in we'll be back real
soon on the Ramsay show
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where dead is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage it's
taken the places of the BMW as America's
status symbol of choice this is where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your money your life I am your
host Jade warshaw joined by the
illustrious whoa George camel thank you
so cool George we got a great show for
you guys today uh hey by the way if you
like this show if you've been listening
to the Ramsay show please please please
consider liking and subscribing to the
show man go on leave a review if you're
listening on YouTube if you're going on
a podcast provider please leave a review
and uh consider sharing that with a
friend it's free it doesn't cost you
anything and we would love if you did
that and uh by the way if you are a new
listener we're happy to have you and we
actually want to dive deeper and if you
want to dive deeper into the Ramsay baby
step apps we want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com and you can click on
the get started button and from there
we'll help you figure out the best next
step on your financial Journey based on
exactly where you're at today so head on
over there go to ramseysolutions.com and
click that get started button all right
George let's get to the phone line let's
do it it looks like we've got Emmy from
Kansas City what you got going on Emmy
hi guys
um
so
I was just calling to see um if I could
get some advice on what to do
considering my current living situation
um I I've been listening to Dave Dave's
advice and everything I'm 27 years old
and a part of me is like why am I
um living with my parents right now I
feel like I'm being irresponsible blah
blah blah
um I mean I have been but
um I I just got out of a bad
relationship a couple months ago and
unfortunately that's kind of a
reoccurring thing where I've been
um
basically living with people and getting
in relationships that are unhousy
because I can't get control of my
financial situation and I'm just now
realizing that
um and so I don't know if I should
continue to live with my parents or if I
should move out
um being 27 and everything now I don't
have anything saved up
but with that being said and the living
situation money's for really tight with
my parents and I live we all are living
in a two-bedroom two-bath apartment
um with my two brothers who are living
and sleeping on the living room floor my
daughter from home and then I also work
from home and selling health insurance
over the phones and we've got three dogs
okay okay wow okay can anyone afford to
move out why is everyone stuck at home
with the parents that's my question
well my my two brothers
um are unable to live on their own so
they've they've continued to live with
my parents and
um so they they're just doing the best
they can my in my mom's health is
um declining quickly and she can't get a
job
um and my dad's just doing the best he
can so are they relying on you to help
pay the bills
um
no I no but it has came up in
conversation
um you know if are you able to help and
um I mean I know that they have taken me
and yeah and helped me so much and so
it's kind of that fine balance and I
um this is my first time I started
watching like your guys's show maybe a
month ago and it's the first time that
any like all of this financial advice is
like just new to me I didn't really have
that growing up are you working
full-time
from home
yes and what are you earning
so um I started the job in January and
have only been on the phones um during
the busiest time of year
um that just ended in December and
um however when I got the job they said
that the average first year agent income
was anywhere from 65 to 72k uh with that
being said I don't know how much I trust
this agency what have you been making
per month
let's see if you're on track for that
well digging into consideration that I
sell health insurance and AEP is like
some agents they make their entire
annual income during those three months
so this is like the most that I've ever
made what is it probably that I will but
um
maybe like 10 000 why didn't I have that
number I I have all my other numbers
prepared for that's okay but I didn't
have that number so you made ten
thousand in month one in one month or or
was that a
um
I
I would say that my average paycheck was
like
2500 and then I made a couple of like uh
5 000 roughly okay and I'm one the 2500
are you getting that twice per month or
is that one one time per month you got
2500 like are you on a bi-weekly pay or
is it once a month pay
um bi-weekly okay so if you were making
if one paycheck was 2500 then let's say
the next one so about 5 000 a month does
that sound about right
yeah okay cool how much debt do you have
well
um watching you guys have really humbled
me
um total debt including student loans
would be 54 000 student loans that
breaks down to
32.9 for student loans I've got a car
that I'm willing to sell
um I I have 18 5 still on that car
um I bought that car specifically
because I can fit a mattress in the back
if that kind of tells you where I've
yeah my mind's been this is tough this
is tough I mean keep going down that
list of debt I want to make sure we can
help you before we run out of time so
student loans car loan anything else
a cell phone I have um 440 on that and
then uh is it like credit cards I've
been using them but I pay them off every
time but that doesn't matter because
eventually cut them up today cut them up
today I'm telling you right now this is
me getting on you as as big sister this
is Mama Jade you cannot okay to use
these credit cards cut them up yeah no
excuses cut them up tonight you don't
need them you got a place to live you
got a place to sleep that's what you
were worried about cut up your credit
cards they are not helping you in this
situation all right okay so I mean we
want to get you cards and I will I will
do that that's well I've lost one of
them so I don't know where that one is
but I'll cut up the rest yes cut up the
rest we want to get you out of the
apartment as soon as you're able
financially so I would start looking
going what do I need to make do I need
to go get a roommate uh can I go find a
responsible female uh maybe it's a
friend or a friend of a friend and vet
them so that you can cut the amount of
rent you're paying down so that we still
have margin to tackle this debt but I
want you to break out of this cycle I
feel like you've stopped believing in
Emmy and you've resigned yourself to
well I'm just a person who gets in bad
relationships and I'm just a person
who's bad with money and I have so much
faith in you that's right you will crawl
out of this and you'll be on the other
side within a few years in a totally
different place financially I agree with
George look we are going to gift you
with a copy of Financial Peace
University and Emmy I want you going
through every single class it's nine
lessons you can work it on your own time
this is going to teach you everything
you need to know in the meantime you're
getting out of your parents house all
right you can do this get your money
saved get through Financial Peace
University and before you know it you're
going to get that debt paid off we're
rooting for you we believe in you we
know that you can do this this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back to the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Jade warshaw joined
Today by George camel we're taking your
calls about life and money but before we
do y'all know tax season is coming up
everybody's favorite time of year George
I just got a little acid reflux when you
said that I need some yeah some Tums
favorite time of year is an
overstatement by far but we want to make
sure that you guys are ready and we have
five five points that we're going to
give you to help you guys prepare for it
but because tax does give us indigestion
for some people it is just the most
boring thing ever but we're gonna make
it fun is that right right we've got
some tax trivia that our team has come
up with and we thought it'll be fun to
quiz you all out there to see if you
know individual state tax law which I'm
sure you've been studying up on for a
while now so here's the deal these are
true or false questions we're going to
throw it out there if you're watching on
YouTube we've got some fun Graphics to
go along with it here's the first
question hit me true or false in Kansas
riding a balloon that is Tethered to the
ground is subject to the amusement tax
true or false oh I feel like we need to
play the Jeopardy music that one's weird
enough that it feels true I'm gonna go
true on this one yeah I would say true
because Kansas folk you know I don't
know I'm just saying that oh she was
about to throw shade at Candy's folks I
used to live
George I'm a former Kansan it is true
and here's the the law behind it if it's
not tethered it's considered
transportation and that is tax free yes
I take my hot air balloon to work all
right there we go take your hot air
balloon to work day all right let's see
this next one George in New Mexico if
you live to be 100 you become tax exempt
is this true or false oh that one also
feels strange enough to be true I would
think I would pray that if I'm a 100 I
ain't paying taxes anymore I feel like
New Mexico rocks that way is it true
let's see
boom if you're not a dependent and
you're a resident by December 31st then
you are tax-free I love how it's written
you're tax-free I love that also I mean
if you make it to 100 give throma bone
you know look if you make it to 100 you
don't have to do nothing you don't want
to do I'm just saying you're out all
right Arkansas taxes its residents for
getting tattoos or body piercings true
or false now if you're in Arkansas and
you've got a tattoo you know because
you've probably paid this tax yeah it's
true wow it's a six percent tax six
percent tax apparently it pays my
goodness it pays to keep that body God
gave you in its most natural state all
natural
well I love this next one okay let's
talk about a little bit of tax evasion
okay
did or did not Nicholas Cage go to court
for tax evasion yeah he's got the face
for it I think he's evaded some taxes in
his day he he's a he's a crazy dude I
gotta believe that he's done some crazy
things yeah are we right yeah it's true
now hopefully hopefully he didn't do it
maybe he got out of it I don't know my
guy needs some help all right who is
this Leo Messi who is an Argentinian
professional football player oh there he
is did he go to court for tax evasion
I'm gonna say yes I feel like
professional athletes like they're not
paying attention to who's handling the
money they get a bad rap is it true
it is true yeah wow I bet you are crying
all right this next one man I already
know that come on Dolly Parton
did she go to court for Texas never
never that Dolly you would never
she's a good woman let's see pull it out
oh false she did not and she maintains
her reputation as America's America's
sweetheart really absolutely I don't
care if you love country music and not
everybody loves Dolly all right George
we gotta get back to the oh we don't
need to get back we had some fun but I
think we need to give them give the
listener some real information let's do
the real people have been asking hey
what's going on with taxes this year
what's changed what do I actually need
to know can you just give me the facts
yeah well let's talk about that we've
got five things here quick details
number one guys you can start to file
your taxes early you do not need to wait
until April you can start by the end of
January so get it done early the filing
deadline is April 18th but you do not
need to wait until April 18th okay you
don't want to be scrambling and
scratching now if you do need to file an
extension the deadline to do that would
make your uh filing deadline October
16th so make sure to get that in uh
George what we got here we got the
standard deduction so that increased is
12 950 for single filers and 25 900 for
married couples filing jointly and
that's a good thing because that reduces
your taxable income which means you're
paying less in taxes that's right and
partially you know thanks to inflation
which income tax brackets also went up
in 2022 to account for inflation they
did and guys we want to warn you about
scams watch out for this because you
you'll get people coming out of the
woodwork talking about tax relief debt
consolidation scams and I want you guys
to know you might come home to emails or
uh phone calls voicemail text messages
or anything of people saying that
they're the IRS they are not the IRS the
IRS will only communicate to you through
the snail mail that's right not even
email it's only if you get a letter in
the mail from the IRS so if you've got
voicemails if you've got anything like
else like that it's a scam and always
check the IRS website for the phone
number if you do get something in the
mail it's a good way to double check
that's right don't just call back any
old number and start handing out your
social security number yeah you can
Google those numbers and it will tell
you if it's a scammer yes so that's a
great reminder for one of our listeners
there another one the IRS was warning
people to wait for these 1099ks but
that's on pause so false alarm and if
you're wondering what the heck the 1099k
is well there was a tax code change that
would have mandated uh Declaration on
any exchanges over these payment apps
like PayPal venmo other cash apps uh if
it was over 600 bucks in exchanges they
wanted their cut but they're waiting
they're going to kick that can down the
road yeah for another year so you don't
have to worry about that which
technically they're entitled to the
taxes but I'm just saying anyway smaller
refunds the IRS warned people to expect
smaller tax refunds this year guys in
2023. think about it we were all used to
that 20 20 money you know what I'm
saying but there were no economic
impacts thank goodness in 2022 so
taxpayers will not get an extra stimulus
payment in their 2023 tax refund check
so I know that y'all y'all were used to
getting that money but it's not going to
they had all the expanded tax credits
and deductions like the child tax credit
charitable contribution deduction but
now it's all reverting to the
pre-covered amount so yeah that's a good
thing that's these tax dollars all right
number five stay away from Advanced
loans I cannot say it loud enough do not
take out a loan for your tax refunds
these ads are everywhere and uh I'm
gonna call them out by name H R Block we
see you we see Turbo Tax we see Jackson
Hewitt we see you we see you trying to
Peddle loans to people for these we'll
get your refund now we'll give you a
loan for it and I'm mad about it we've
already look you've already loaned your
money tax-free and interest free to the
government all right interest free
you've been giving them your money every
paycheck and now they want to turn
around and offer you a loan for your own
money don't don't do it don't take the
bait just wait and get your refund all
right that's all we need to do so I want
you guys to know that we've got you
covered as far as all the resources that
you're going to need for this tax season
head over to ramseysolutions.com
taxes you're going to find everything
that you need for this 20 23 tax season
all right I love it man oh man oh man
George
let's see do we have time to take this
call let's take a look at it we got uh
we can hold yeah we'll hold and let's
see Bill what we got going on in Wichita
Kansas all right let's get straight to
the question yeah
all right I wanted to buy some land and
move out of town and I can give you my
financial stance real fast if you'd like
sure yeah we got time
um so the land signs were 125 I can get
9 and 75 of it borrowed for a loan for a
20-year loan
I owe 125 on my house I make 18 my wife
makes 15.50 and it was that an hour 20
000
yes okay okay eighteen eight you make 18
an hour she makes 15.50 an hour
yes okay and the land is 10 acres and
has a shop on it that we live in until
fave to build a house later on five ten
years do you have any debt
nope debt free debt free how much money
do you have
in the bank
uh we've got uh about nine grand
and is it was that going to be your down
payment or is that your emergency fund
or what
um so the down payment is equity I have
my house because I only owe 125 and I
can sell for about 180 to 190. okay so
you'd have about 50 in equity 45 or so
yeah I I would use about 20 to build it
to make it livable okay well what is
this 20-year loan that doesn't sound
like a conventional mm-hmm
what kind of noise is a land loan since
it's not residential I can't get a
regular mortgage on it ah what's the
interest rate of all the stuff on the
land
um it's about six to seven percent that
varies every day
um but it already has that big there has
gas has water internet has everything
there the house over there had burned
down man I might pause on this and stack
up more cash so that that puts you in a
better financial position in order to
pay off this new mortgage so I would I'd
walk slowly with this and try to get the
income up so that you can cover all of
the new expenses with this land project
that's right I agree with what with what
George is saying we don't want to get
into too much and bite off more than
what you can chew this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show this
is Jade and I've got George here and
guys in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions on
the debt-free stage we got Daniel and
Cody guys it's nice to have you how are
you guys doing good how are you doing
well how are you we're doing great where
are you guys from Sumter South Carolina
Sumter South Carolina so you're in here
you got to do your debt free scream how
much did you guys pay off
two hundred eighteen thousand one
hundred and one dollars yep what kind of
debt was it our house whoa yeah
what yep I love it wow how long did that
take you guys 13 months wow there's a
story here yes sir yes there is because
that that's Godlike amazing so tell us a
story what was the range of income
during that time how did you guys make
this happen in 13 months
so um we he's military and we moved to
South Carolina in the midst of covid and
bought a house
um he was working I was not so I got my
real estate license and we went from 60
000 to 330 000. hey oh what yeah wow was
that from Real Estate
yeah so you just got your license and
then you just crushed it year one killed
it you killed it I mean what did you
make your first year of Real Estate
well I started in July so I made 40 000
my first half of the year and on the
next year 292. oh my goodness that is
incredible unbelievable and have you
been able to keep that going like have
you just yeah yeah oh my goodness he
tells me every day if I don't sell a
house I can't come home so wow
apparently you're you're doing it she's
home every night oh my goodness Cody was
like the secret hot sauce she was
serious sauce and Cody thank you for
your service and sacrifice man that you
guys are incredible couple yes sir man
this is exciting stuff so like you know
how did you find out about FPU how did
you get started on this whole journey
like what made you want to pay off the
house uh I would say it all started
during college
um Cody's mom is really big into Dave
Ramsey so we first learned through her
that we need to get through college debt
free which we both did and then we both
saw how much our house costs and then
how much we're going to pay in interest
and said absolutely not wow so it
started you pre-decided Daniel to go
like we're not gonna have this debt
sitting around absolutely yeah wow
seeing how much money we were going to
pay that didn't go to anything
on the fact that you went through
college without student loans so you
guys are just smart people you guys are
smarter than the average bear how old
are you two
I'm 27 he's 26. oh wow wow wow wow I
cannot wait please tell me you'll come
back when you're when your baby steps
millionaires yeah hopefully because it
ain't gonna be long I'm nervous it's
going to be like they're going to come
back tomorrow and be like we did it yeah
the goal flees by 30. yeah I love that
yeah well incredible wow so tell me when
you guys were on this journey uh Cody
you start doing real estate you guys are
getting just getting busy did anybody
were there any naysayers were folks
telling you you don't need to pay off
your mortgage tell me what that was like
yeah I would say there's tons of people
that think like that or oh you have such
a low interest rate why would you pay
your house off
um what would you say to that
I'd say you're not very intelligent with
your money yes
behind your desk and tell them I know
right
we knew that he wasn't going to stay in
the military and so are and he wasn't
quite sure what he wanted to do either
so we were like how can we not have a
bill and then you decide and not have to
worry about anything once you once you
get out so we actually created our own
amortization chart and said Okay a month
before you get out we're gonna have our
house paid off and it was like six six
thousand extra a month to the principal
that we had to pay WOW and then we just
started we were like we kind of have
money floating around we can pay this
off quicker so then we just started so
you guys realizing we could have like
options if we didn't have a mortgage
yeah and the secret sauce is you just
paid extra on the principle of the
mortgage yeah people are always trying
to come up with a hack and if you do
like if you do one extra payment and you
guys just said no let's just slap an
extra 6 000 a month on this thing yeah
instead of having lifestyle creeps set
in because you guys could have spent
some money
yeah I think that's what ultimately we
learned from this is that discipline is
going to get us to wherever we want to
go so if we're able to say no to the
short gains then ultimately we're going
to have a lot at the end man so how does
that feel I mean you made that final
mortgage payment what month did you make
the final payment April of 22. oh so how
I mean explain tell the people because I
think people need to know that this is a
real feeling like something truly
happens inside of you what did it feel
like that first month that you didn't
have a mortgage payment and all the
income that you were bringing in was
just yours I would say honestly felt
weird because we didn't have a mortgage
payment so we have the extra money left
over that was great
um I would say it's truly freeing
knowing that I don't owe anybody
anything extra don't owe anybody
anything now most people go well you
guys aren't enjoying life at all
would you say that is untrue have you
been living the money too we just came
back from an eight day cruise over
Christmas come on so we're here like
shaking this is exciting so if we're not
living that I don't really know what
these feelings are okay she said if this
ain't living I don't know what it is
most people are like well YOLO fomo I
gotta live my life I can't just sit
there trying to pay off all this debt
like I'll pay it off when it gets paid
off 30 years from now or you can live
that way after you pay off all your
debts okay I mean you can be baby steps
millionaires when you're 30 okay that's
what I'm talking about I'm excited well
we know the Mother-in-law was a big
cheerleader who got you guys started on
this who are some of your other like who
are the people that I mean when when
times got hard you were like I gotta
call so and so because I need to stay
focused how did you guys stay focused we
have an awesome Church community just
our a group of friends and then we
actually had some people
um Chris and Maria shout out to them
they were great encouragers as well and
I would say for me the biggest
encourager was Daniel
um
there were times where I would come home
and be like I feel like I'm working so
hard and then it's just going to that
going to that and he would just keep
encouraging me and telling me like this
is not going to be a long process and
we're kind of being silly thinking that
it's going to be a long process it's
going quick so yeah he was awesome I
love it you guys it was amazing from my
perspective just watching her bringing
all this stuff keep going it's a good
deal man so what are you guys doing now
what's the next goal yeah
we want to own a million dollars before
we're 30. so wow we're saving up right
now to purchase rental properties and
and that's amazing yeah crush it with
that
yeah what's the house worth
um our house like 270 275. I love it
incredible incredible incredible well
guys uh we've got a live and give box
for you that's the next step in your
journey inside of it there's a copy of
baby steps millionaires that's for you
and then there's a copy of The Total
Money Makeover that's free to give away
plus one year of FPU you can pass this
forward give it to somebody else this
information has obviously changed your
life and I'm sure you can't wait to
share that with somebody else so they
can change their life but now it's the
time that we've all been waiting for
guys all right we've got on the stage
right now Daniel and Cody they have paid
off two hundred and eighteen thousand
dollars in 13 months making 330
000 income guys let's hear it a debt
free scream count it down three three
two one we're debt free
[Music]
[Applause]
wait I'm oh I'm not getting in their way
I'm certainly not getting in Cody's way
because she she's on that real estate
train she'll plow me right down goodness
gracious that's the way you do it George
it is
[Applause]
with having the right inputs having the
right material right education the right
people in your life yeah and you know
what I like is the the Mother-in-law the
mom came in and said hey this is you
guys need to do this and you need to get
on this plan this is going to change
your life and and they did it they took
the advice you know I think about that
scripture that says fools despise wisdom
and fools despise discipline fools
despise understanding but these people
these ain't no fools these people heard
it they went they followed what the
Mother-in-law said and they got on a
plan it changed their life George well
when you can just swallow your pride and
go hey my financial plan uh it ain't
working I'm gonna try this one over here
and what if I could just live a
debt-free life what if I could have a
paid for house by the time I'm 26 it's
that kind of vision that creates the
right habits that actually creates the
right results exactly for most people
they're not willing to do what Cody and
Daniel did no they'd rather sit in their
own filth and go well I'm just gonna sit
here and just keep Meandering through
life YOLO fomo and they decided no we
can really live big time if we're
willing to live like no one else right
now yep gotta live like no one else now
so later you can live and give like no
one else and no one's gonna do it for
you mama can't do it for you Daddy can't
do it for you it's you changing your
mind and you deciding that I can't live
like this anymore I want a better future
I want a better life I can have a better
life
all you got to do is look at Daniel and
Cody they changed their life
I love doing it George this is why we do
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all right we're back you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm Jade
this is George we got our scripture and
quote of the day says this but you are
chosen people a royal priesthood a royal
Nation God's special possession that you
may declare the Praises of him who
called you out of Darkness into his
wonderful light that's first Peter 2 9
and then Prince said this my favorite my
guy Prince despite everything no one can
dictate who you are to other people I
know that's right Prince he came along
with it
so George
it's a new year it is and thank you Lord
and that means you can't be given up on
the goals George that you set out to
accomplish this year and neither can you
guys and if your main goal was to build
those money muscles but you've only been
to the money gym once personal attack
Jake
I'm not trying to George I've been twice
but for those listeners out there if
you've only been to that money gym once
just like everything else man it's time
to start making progress and stop making
excuses please I know that it can be
hard when you don't have a plan or if
you're just starting out or if you're
like my husband and I and you're trying
to climb and Claw and scratch your way
out of 460 000 of debt it's tough but
let me tell you something if you want a
practical proven plan to climb out from
whatever debt you might be facing
whatever bills if you want to start
Building Wealth you need to grab
yourself a copy of The Total Money
Makeover guys I cannot tell you enough
this book has literally changed our
lives it's literally the reason that I'm
sitting here today next to the
illustrious George camel wow this is
Dave's best-selling book for a reason
guys you will learn the seven baby steps
to guide you through your money Journey
with real life stories from people they
don't have to struggle for money anymore
Guys these are real life stories because
they followed these proven principles as
well and let's be real
with you paying off debt with you
Building Wealth I can tell you this it's
for you it's not just for those people
out there it's not just for the people
that you see on TV it's not just for
your neighbors the Joneses Building
Wealth paying off debt it is for you too
so get back on that money treadmill
today and Order yourself a copy of The
Total Money Makeover you can find it at
ramseysolutions.com
store and I tell you right now you got
this you can do it America George let's
get to the phone lines you can give us a
call today at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and we've got
Phil Phil's on the line here from Grand
Rapids Michigan how can we help you
today Phil
hey there Jay George thanks for your
time appreciate it no problem how can we
help
well my wife and I were both 33 years
old and for the past eight years now
we've had the goal of starting a family
but we've been faced with the challenges
of frankly overcoming some unexplained
infertility
um we're currently halfway through baby
steps 3A okay
um so we feel the urgency to start a
family due to our age of course although
at the same time we don't want to lose
our gazelle intensity and get distracted
um so
so doing some research we'd really like
to be able to cash flow embryo adoption
okay where would you put this in the
baby steps and what percentage of income
would you dedicate towards it well
there's a couple ways we can look at
this what's your income right now
uh we have a combined gross income of
100K awesome gross that's good
and where are you at in the emergency
fund how many months would you say you
have right now
um
we're we're over halfway we probably
have about another four months until
until it's fully funded would you say
You have about three months of expenses
yeah we have about three months saved up
so far okay okay
um
as you've priced this out what are some
of the what's your research telling you
that this is going to cost you price
wise
yeah for all the research um
approximately about fifteen thousand
fifteen thousand that's not that's not
I've heard some so how quickly let's say
you you guys stop right now you're right
you've got three months of expenses
saved if you just did nothing but save
up for this embryo adoption how quickly
could you save up fifteen thousand
making 100k
um we'd probably be able to do that
um
each of the fire probably six eight
months and is that money owed up front
it's it's it's due along the way
um so it's not all up front oh well
that's a great they come in very large
chunks though normally two to three
grand at a time so I'm wondering if you
guys could you had five grand could you
start the process and then you get the
next five a few months later and the
next five a few months later
so that you can get started on this
yeah have you guys been investing at all
um we have not ever since um starting
our our debt-free journey we have we
have uh done zero investing okay so you
pause that great yeah you know I think
George has a good plan I if 15K is a lot
of money but at the same time I've I've
heard it priced out higher so I was
happy to hear it on the what I've seen
heard as the lower end of the spectrum
so that's good
um if you had six months of savings set
aside I might say you could pull a
little from there but because you only
have three months I really don't want to
dwindle your savings anymore because
typically you know in the case of
somebody having a baby we would say
pause all the baby steps and pile up as
much money as you can you know to get
ready for this big life change you know
it's a medical procedure so there's a
lot of things that are associated with
it and we want you to be ready for that
so that's the only reason and a big a
good reason why I would say hey in this
case I wouldn't dip into 3A uh your baby
step or your I'm sorry your savings
account however I think that what George
was saying is great you guys should be
able to cash flow this and I love that
it's not this big long some that's due
at once but you can kind of as you get
to those different Milestones uh pay
what what the next fee is how does that
sit with you Phil
yeah yeah that uh that sounds good
um that was our big thing of just uh
being able to get into a place of our
own and our ultimate goal is having my
wifey stay at home and you know so uh
I'm having something we can cash flow is
definitely and even temporarily if you
want to pick up side hustles you want to
sell some stuff you want to ratchet down
that budget as much as you can that
could help get this first five thousand
let's say in the next two months to get
the process started and you know create
that timeline of hey when are the Bills
going to be due when are we going to
have this money and if an emergency does
pop up we pause and go all right we've
gotta make sure this is covered you have
three months worth which should cover
you through this process but I think
it's a worthwhile goal to do whatever
you can to stack up this money and get
the process started absolutely you know
you know with George when it comes to
family planning planning for children
fertility we always you know we always
recommend don't don't forego having a
family to get out of debt don't forego
having a family I mean that's a really
important thing but there's a way that
you can go through that process and do
it the right way so and once you've got
the treatment paid for then we can save
up more we can begin investing for the
future and you guys are 33 you've got a
long life ahead of you and we're wishing
you the best on that fertility Journey
that can be so so tough yeah yeah thanks
for the call all right we've got Alicia
in Sacramento California what's going on
Alicia
hi there uh good afternoon I was
wondering if it would be a good idea to
refi on my house
um I've had some unexpected things come
up like a pipe first or broke and um the
repairs are really expensive it's like
about 11 000. but it means like I have
in those things and no dishwasher no
laundry and I have a baby on the way in
about like five months and it's just me
and then also my car broke down and then
I had some debt so I'm looking to see if
it was good to refi to pay off the debt
and uh to get the repairs done and to
like have some emergency funds in time
yeah so you're thinking you want to roll
the cost of that into a new mortgage
are you doing a cash out refi is that
what you do is take out equity
yes okay
yeah we would never suggest to do
something like that Alicia we want you
to pay off your debt using the debt
snowball we would never want you to
leverage or put that kind of strain on
your mortgage since that's your that's
your living situation and like you said
you've got a baby on the way
um what's your income
of me income is like
I'm at the lowest I make 3 200 a month
at the highest 4 400 a month
so it's like I'm struggling if I'm at
the minimum I'm trying to work as much
overtime as I can
um but like I just don't think I would
make it in time before she gets here how
many more months until she gets here
about five months five months yeah so in
five months we need to save up and we
need to cover this repair ASAP uh is the
home worth selling right now because of
your situation and downsizing
[Music]
um
I thought about selling the house which
is that I don't see any other places to
go into
well it may be wise to rent for a while
and get back on your feet financially
and will become a homeowner later down
the road but right now we've got a storm
we got a baby on the way as a single mom
there's a lot to be thinking about
that's right we're gonna get you hooked
up with Financial Peace University and
as part of that you're going to have
access to some Financial coaching and
that's going to help you on your journey
on the way to becoming motherhood and to
get you set up with your money guys
thanks for listening today this is the
Ramsay show hey George camel here if you
love the show and you want a deeper dive
on your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]